[موسيقى]
اهلا مرحبا مرحبا
اتسيمس ولكن
البدايه ان هذه القضيه قضيه ومساله
الشخصيه بينك وبين رجب طيب اردوغان طيب
لماذا هذه المساله الشخصيه بينكم
اكثر
للصحافه الحره في تركيا
بسببه ما نقلته مباشره بشان مساعدتي ودعم
الحكومه التركيه للارهابيين في سوريا
وارسال الاسلحه بصوره غير قانونيه فكان
ذلك اشبهها بالقبض على اردوغان متلبسه فلم
يروق له ذلك بصراحه
الشخصيه بالاحرى يعتبر كما لو انه عمل ضد
الدوله
ما يحدث تقريبا في ظل جميع السلطات
الاستبداديه في كل مكان اذا قمت بانتقاد
مصالح الحكومه تنعت بالارهابي والخائن
تعيش في المانيا حاليا ولكن مره اخرى بعد
نقلك للمعلومات الرئيس اردوغان قال وقت بس
يجب ان تدفع الثمن وبعد اطلاق سراحك هاجم
المحكمه الدستوريه وعندما زار المانيا في
2018 طلب ترحيلك وتسلمك هذا رفض بالطبع
ولكن على رغم ذلك
هل تشعر انك مهدد هل حياتك
في المانيا حاليا
نعم هذا مؤسف ان لاردوغان ازرع طويله في
اوروبا
الخداع والابتزاز مع الحكومات الاوروبيه
بهدفي ترحيل اشخاص مثلك من المؤسف انه
ينجح احيانا في ذلك في حالتي هناك دعوه
قانونيه
استخدام الانترنت
مؤخرا مكتب المدعي العام لاسطنبول
العامه
طبيعيه
في عام 2013
[موسيقى]
بالانضميه لحلف شمال الاطلسيه هل انتقلق
باستعمال تركيا لهذه المسائل مثلا العضويه
فعل الشمال الاطلسي ومسائل اخرى اوكرانيا
مثلا
لتسليم اشخاص مطلوبين لديهم مثلك
تماما تماما هذه هي تكتكات اردوغان وهو
استخدم ذلك لسنوات طويله وللاسف احيانا
ينجح في ذلك هو هناك ورقه الناتو وهو
يحاول ان يعرقل انضمام السويد وفيلا الى
الحلم
ومن اجل استعادته الى تركيا
عندما الامر يتعلق بالمسائل الامنيه فان
المسائل المتعلقه بحقوق الانسان تصبح
ثانويه
ان السويد
قررت لارضاء اردوغان ان تغير الدستور فيما
يتعلق بتعريف الارهاب وبالتالي حصل
اردوغان على ما يريد هذا فيه شيء من العار
همم علينا ان نرى الدول الاوروبيه متشبثه
بحقوقها الانسان والقيم
حسنا الان بشكل عام كيف يمكنك ان تصف حاله
وسائل الاعلام في بلدك تركيا صنفت في
المرتبه المائه والتسعه واربعين على 180
دوله ااه من خلال مؤشر حريه الصحافه
لمراسيلون بلا حدود في سنه 2012
[موسيقى]
الى رجال الاعمال في تركيا
من وسائل الاعلام يتم التحكم بها من قبل
اردوغان اما الباقون هم اما مهددون او في
السجون هناك فقط وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
او وسائل الاعلام في المنفى مثلنا
واما يتم حجمه او يتم اعتماد قانون لوسائل
الاعلام الجديد من اجل تعطيل وسائل
الاعلام قبل الانتخابات
من قبل البرلمان في اكتوبر اصبح بموجه بها
العاملون في وسائل الاعلام ومستخدمين
الشبكات الاجتماعيه وارضى للسجن 3 سنوات
لنشرها ما يسمى باخبار كاذبه هل تعتبر او
تعتبر بان هذه اداه تمكن النظام من حجب
وسائل الاعلام حتى وان كانت في المنفى
وكذلك الشبكات الاجتماعيه
لدى جورج اورويل في كتابه 1984 ليس الهدف
هو مكافحه التصديل بل نشر الاخبار المضلله
همم لصالح الحكومه وهم يحاولون تعطيل
الصحفيين الذين يعلمون الجمهور ويعطون
الاخبار الموثوقه وذات المصداقيه بالتالي
همم
كل اجهزه الاعلام التقليديه في تركيا
والان يستهدفون وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
من السهل القاء الاتهامات جوزافا
بنشر اخبار كاذبه عند الحديث عن الاخبار
الحقيقيه
للتضخم او اصابات يمكن
اعتبار ذلك اخبار كاذبه والقاء الشخص في
السجن لمده ثلاث سنوات والهدف من ذلك
ونشره الرعب والخوف لدى الجمهور
وهم يحاولون حجمها موقعنا وهم يحاول اخافه
الجمهور حتى لا يتواصلوا مع مواقع ومع
اجهزه الاعلام الاخرى الان قبل سته اشهر
قبيل الانتخابات وهذا كله يصب في مصلحته
اخي لالي تعطيل الاخبار ذات المصداقيه
قبيل الانتخابات
ويبدو ان هذه الانتخابات ستكون فيها
المنافسه محتدمه
هذه الانتخابات لن يكون منصفا وحتى ان
الانتخابات في حد ذاتها لن تكون منصفه
عادله
علينا ان نتصوره
من قبل الحكومه على السلطه القضائيه وسائل
الاعلام اردوغان يتحكموا بسلطوطات
البرلمان والاعلام والقضاء والجيش والقوات
المسلحه
وان النظام القضائي لا يسير بشكل جيد
وبالتالي عملنا صعب جدا
كل ما ذكرته مع كل هذه السلطات التي
يمتلكها فان كل استطلاعات الراي تقريبا
تبين ان نتائج خطيره بالنسبه له بانه قد
يخسر لذا جاهدا للتشبث بالسلطه اعتقدوا
بان القمع سيزداد في الاشهر القادمه وهو
يحاول شنن عمليه عسكريه ضد سوريا ولقد هدد
البارحه اليونان
في الواقع يسعى الى خلقه اجواء من الفوضى
لاقناع الناس لان تركيا بحاجه الى زعيم
قوي بدل حكومه ائتلافيه
على برنامج حوار
[موسيقى]